e
là
le
moi
gay pride gueuler berrichonne traduisons
soyons fiers dans l'être libérons nous
soyons fier d'en être homosexuel ces
hommes ces femmes qui manifestent devant
des passants un peu interloqué sous la
protection de la police avec un drapeau
américain se proclame que même pédéraste
et lesbiennes leur mouvement et leur
mouvement de libération des homosexuels
en amérique
cette manifestation se déroule à new
york ville où l'on en a vu d'autres
ailleurs en amérique il faut bien le
dire elle ferait scandale dans la
plupart des villes américaines
les homosexuels sont l'objet de la
suspicion populaire ils sont écartés de
beaucoup d'emplois et ne peuvent en
principe prétendre à aucune carrière
politique
c'est justement ce contre quoi le
mouvement de libération des homosexuels
entend protester à leur manière les
homosexuels américains réclament ce que
réclame beaucoup de minorités
américaines être intégrée tout en
affichant sa différence à leur manière
aussi ils prétendent réunir dans leur
confrérie des gens de toutes classes de
toutes conditions et de toutes races
inutile d'ajouter que la majorité
silencieuse qui soutient le président
nixon contemple à la télévision ce genre
de manifestation d'un oeil auront